[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes
me gustaría empezar esta charla con una
pregunta muy sencilla y muy corta os
gusta el arte imagino que sí verdad a
todos nos gusta el arte a todos nos
gusta disfrutar de un buen cuadro de
verdad y tenemos la suerte pues que a lo
largo de los años se han elaborado
varios cuadros importantes que han
marcado la historia de la misma
humanidad me gustaría por ejemplo
mencionar un cuadro importante de seurat
que se llama un tarde de domingo en la
gran isla de chet este cuadro del siglo
19 marcó bastante la historia del arte
porque pues por varios motivos entre los
cuales seguramente estaba esa técnica no
el puntillismo que quiere decir pues
pintar con puntos y al final el
resultado final de estos puntos el
conjunto de estos puntos nos daba este
cuadro tan bonito pero bueno si nos
fijamos en solamente unos puntos quizás
perdemos un poco lo bonito que es el
cuadro algunos datos importantes de este
cuadro está compuesto por fijaros tres
millones y medio de puntos tres millones
y medio de puntos y el pintor segura
tardó dos años dos años en dibujar este
cuadro pero claro el resultado final fue
bastante importante marcó la historia
del arte de este siglo ahora bien la
charla está enfocada en personalidad e
internacionalización verdad
qué tiene que ver el arte el positivismo
con esta parte bueno esta pregunta
importante me gustaría que le
contestaremos todos juntos todos juntos
pero al final de la sala y quizás cada
uno le podría contestar de una forma
relativa pero ya lo veremos vamos un
poco paso a paso hemos dicho que esta
charla se basa en la personalidad por un
lado y internacionalización por lo tanto
qué es la personalidad como podríamos
interpretar la personalidad bueno si nos
fijamos en esa definición literaria de
la palabra personalidad es una
derivación directa de la palabra persona
y la palabra persona en el latino
antiguo pues hacía referencia a la
máscara que utilizaban los varios
actores para interpretar un papel por lo
tanto de alguna forma podríamos decir
que esa definición
digamos inicial de la persona edad era
nuestra apariencia como los demás nos
ven
seguramente esa definición ha cambiado
continuamente y varios estudiosos entre
los cuales el mismo freud pues han
intentado dar definiciones una
definición que creo que aporta bastante
esta definición de diamond cat él
vale la definición suya básicamente
el estudio un poco de la sanidad y la
definición suya consistía en lo que
hemos puesto ahí es una estructura
mental que se obtiene de la observación
coherente de un determinado
comportamiento y se compone de rasgos
únicos y comunes en este estudio el
identifico 16 factores de los cuales 5
factores las clasificó como factores
principales en estos factores
principales tenemos algunos importantes
por ejemplo la abertura hacía nuevas
experiencias
quiere decir cambiar un poco esta
mentalidad y salir un poco de la zona de
confort pues para vivir nuevas
experiencias aún más tenemos otras y la
extraversión esta abertura nuestra hacia
los demás otro factor fundamental era la
responsabilidad quiere decir establecer
objetivos y trabajar de forma proactiva
para poder cumplir con esos objetivos
y tenemos la amabilidad es decir ser de
alguna forma empático empatizar con los
demás
también tenemos la estabilidad emocional
a su vez estos cinco factores o factores
fundamentales que hemos mencionado se
influyen por dos variables principales
expedidas personales y el entorno
ahora fijaros la mente una feliz acción
es un factor transversal a todos porque
gracias a la internacionalización
podríamos vivir nuevas experiencias
ampliar ese entorno y por lo tanto
modificar y mejorar posiblemente nuestra
personalidad
bueno como hemos llegado a esta
conclusión pues en mi caso yo hice como
un estudio analizando algunas fases de
mi vida
me gustaría compartirla con vosotros
empezamos por esta primera imagen posó
en algo
no verdad a lo mejor a samuel si esta
imagen que vemos aquí
es el país se llama albania y yo soy da
el baño
y es el país donde yo nací y viví hasta
hasta los 18 años por lo tanto de alguna
forma esta imagen es representa
gráficamente pues ese entorno que
definió mi personalidad en este momento
cómo definiría yo mi personalidad en
este punto de mi vida pues tú definiría
teniendo en cuenta esos cinco factores
que hemos visto anteriormente como la
personalidad un poco joven y
poco digamos bastante moderada por
varios factores tampoco tenía muchísimas
responsabilidades porque vivía con mi
familia quizás la única vía más
preocupación para mí en este momento era
estudiar y posiblemente sacar buenas
notas
y el entorno para mí era muy bien
definido era en este caso mi familia mis
amigos mi ciudad y quizás el país lo
demás y estaba un poco fuera pues entre
comillas de algunas formas pues tampoco
no era tan importante para mi problema
que pasó en 2009 me ofrecieron una
oportunidad pues para estudiar fuera
para estudiar en este caso en italia y
fueran decisión como podéis imaginar no
tan fácil porque para mí en este momento
quiero dejar a mi país quería decir
dejar a mis amigos dejar a mi madre sola
porque mi hermana se había casado hace
poco y entrar en otro país que tampoco
conocía que tampoco conocía muy bien así
que podéis imaginar que fue una decisión
bastante complicada y tardamos un poco
en tomar esa decisión pero al final
pensamos de forma proactiva no hemos
dicho bueno hace falta hace falta hace
esta experiencia porque como mínimo como
mínimo vas a tener más oportunidades
tanto laborales como académicas y con
esa decisión
en el 2019 en bolonia una ciudad
preciosa por cierto al principio podéis
imaginar los primeros meses si nada el
idioma es la barrera importante sin
conocer a mucha gente sin tener amigos
pero bueno esos primeros meses pasan
rápido y una vez que pasa y ya te
sientes otra vez cómodo con este nuevo
entorno y analizando ahora mismo y
personalidad en este punto seguramente
creo que ha mejorado algo porque hemos
modificado el entorno ahora sí que le
preocupa no solamente para mi país pero
también para los nuevos amigos que he
hecho en italia pues la nueva ciudad he
ampliado el entorno y además he tenido
la posibilidad de poder hacer o vivir
nuevas experiencias por lo tanto
teniendo en cuenta la personalidad y la
interpretación con esos cinco factores
principales todo ellos crecen crecen
porque he conseguido ampliar el entorno
y de alguna forma he vivido
nuevas experiencias
luego llegamos en 2016 en el 2016 nos
ofrecen oportunidades académicas y
laborales tanto a mí como a mi mujer
como a mí para atrás la trasladarnos en
españa y al principio fue un poco bueno
que hacemos dejamos todo ahora que
tenemos cierta estabilidad que tenemos
unos amigos tenemos bastante un entorno
bastante estado vamos a hacer como el
club de entorno nos mudamos hacia otro
país y es una pregunta que te comentaba
continuamente pero bueno al final
siempre de forma proactiva y con
positividad decidimos bien este es el
momento para hacer el cambio nos vamos
para españa si en los peores de los
casos en los peores de los casos lo que
vamos a aprender de estaciones de esta
nueva experiencia es el idioma el
castellano y es una ventaja importante
con esa decisión en la cabeza
decidimos pues mudarnos para españa y
nos venimos pues en toledo la verdad que
como siempre los primeros meses un poco
complicados pero bueno esos primeros
meses pasan y pasan bastante rápido
así que como interpretaría yo mi
personalidad en este momento en españa
seguramente por lo que hemos dicho
anteriormente no tanto el entorno como
las nuevas experiencias han mejorado mi
personalidad y hacemos y hacemos
referencia con este cuadro que hemos
presionado al principio hemos añadido
varios puntitos en este dibujo inicial y
además ampliando el entorno hemos
ampliado este ángulo de vista hacia el
cuadro quiere decir que estamos
aprovechando y quizás de alguna forma
mejor el cuadro y está nuestra
personalidad y luego yacamán el 2018 el
2018 nos ofrecen una oportunidad pues
para dejar a españá esta vez y para
mudarnos a eeuu claro al principio la
decisión fue un poco como siempre
complicada que hacemos otra vez dejamos
todo para mudarnos a un nuevo país que
no conocíamos y es una pregunta que nos
perseguía continuamente pero al final
siempre con esta productividad y con la
positividad decidimos miel vamos a
trasladarnos a eeuu aunque
conozcamos el país sabiendo que hay un
contraste cultural además en el sur de
eeuu bastante importante pero aun así
decidimos lo vamos a hacer a por ello y
fue así que en 2018 nos mudamos a eeuu
precisamente en richmond que sería la
parte la capital del sur eeuu al
principio pues esas primeras
experiencias complicadas como siempre
pero como no conocíamos y me acuerdo muy
bien el choque cultural importante por
hacerlos un ejemplo los coches los
coches super mega grandes y en europa
pues tenemos un coche más pequeños ahí
sería el pick up de merkel más que local
pero bueno al final te acostumbras y
vivimos ahí
casi un año y la verdad es que estamos
bastante a gusto hasta diciembre 2010 y
9 en diciembre 2019 pues también algo
cambia de nuevo nos ofrece pues una
posibilidad laboral para volver otra vez
a españa pero fijaros gracias así a esas
experiencias continuas pues en este caso
no teníamos miedo de volver atrás porque
ya conocíamos ese entorno y cómo sería
haciendo una breve interpretación cómo
sería mi personalidad como creo que
sería en mi personalidad en este momento
me dieron eeuu pues seguramente todos
esos cinco factores se habían
incrementado bastante porque por lo que
hemos dicho varias veces porque hemos
incrementado el entorno vale que nos
pregunta este entorno socioeconómico que
define nuestra personalidad y además
hemos vivido varias experiencias
y en 2019 nos miraremos otra vez en
españa esta vez sin miedo sin miedo
porque gracias a las grandes
experiencias que habíamos hecho
anteriormente conocíamos muy bien el
entorno por lo tanto no nos daba más
miedo en móvil y así fue así que
decidimos volver en toledo y la verdad
que la decisión ha sido bastante
acertada pensando un poco en la
personalidad en este momento pues yo
creo que es una personalidad con los
cinco factores bastantes altos y esto
gracias a las varias experiencias que he
hecho pues durante mi vida
laboral y académica en los varios países
ahora bien me gustaría terminar esta
charla con un comentario
sencillo y que creo que un mensaje
importante
recordaros todos todos sois pintores
todos tenéis ese poder para hacer un
cuadro una obra de arte que se llama
vuestra personalidad y además acordaros
una obra de arte no lo aprecia
solamente el pintor sino que también los
demás por lo tanto está vosotros
trabajar para poder generar esta obra de
arte y para generar buenas condiciones
para todos nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
sí
[Música]